[Música]
es considerada por muchos como la
democracia más grande del mundo
1300 millones de habitantes de múltiples
etnias razas e idiomas estamos hablando
de India la economía de este país es una
de las más grandes del mundo de hecho
está entre las 10 más grandes de acuerdo
al producto interno bruto y está en
constante expansión es un exportador
global masivo y una potencia agrícola y
es el hogar de 10 de las ciudades de más
rápido crecimiento en el mundo eso en
cuanto al ámbito político en económico
pero políticamente hace parte también de
otros bloques internacionales como por
ejemplo el grupo de los bricks y ha
insistido en mantener una neutralidad
para seguir comerciando con Rusia y pese
al rechazo del mundo occidental Nueva
Delhi consiguió que se dieran y ellos
pudieran mantener a India alejada de las
disputas internacionales Cómo entender
entonces la posición de este país
asiático frente a las tensiones que hay
a nivel internacional
tiene una excelente relación comercial y
militar con Rusia comparte con china
varios escenarios Como por ejemplo el de
los bricks pero disputan la presencia y
la fortaleza a nivel regional sobre todo
en la Cuenca del Índico y también tiene
muy buenas relaciones con Estados Unidos
y con Europa Pero eso sí mantiene
tensiones con el vecino Pakistán A qué
le apuesta India en su política exterior
Qué papel juega en los conflictos que
hay a nivel mundial Como por ejemplo la
Guerra de Ucrania la atención con Taiwán
y la atención que hay también con Rusia
y China a nivel internacional Cuál es su
rol en el mundo India geopolítica en
tiempos de tensión en nuestro tema de
hoy en el debate de France 24 y para
analizar este tema hemos invitado a
Sabrina Olivera ella es magister y
doctorada en relaciones internacionales
también es especialista en la región de
Asia Pacífico ella se encuentra en la
ciudad de Buenos Aires también allí en
la capital argentina se encuentra
nuestra siguiente invitada Clara Sánchez
ella es magister en relaciones y
negociaciones internacionales es
integrante del grupo de trabajo del sur
de Asia en el consejo argentino de
relaciones internacionales le dicen
recuerdo que ustedes también hacen parte
de esta conversación ustedes ya lo saben
pueden dejar preguntas y también los
comentarios a través de las redes
sociales y estamos en Twitter en
Instagram y en Facebook en donde no se
encuentran como arroba
france24_es@santilogo que es mi cuenta
personal la etiqueta para que dejen sus
comentarios numeral el debate f24 en
YouTube también encuentran nuestra señal
en streaming y pueden dejar sus
comentarios a través del chat en vivo
saludamos también a las personas que nos
están escuchando a través del podcast
todos los contenidos del debate de
France 24 ya están disponibles en
diferentes plataformas en Apple podcast
en Spotify deezer y tuning
Bueno pues le doy la bienvenida entonces
a Sabrina la ciudad de Buenos Aires
Sabrina como siempre Un gusto tenerla en
el programa Gracias por acompañarnos hoy
Punto de partida primera pregunta para
conocer posiciones de los invitados
desde su punto de vista Sabrina le
parece que India está desafiando a
occidente al mantener una relación
estrecha con Rusia dado el contexto que
estamos viviendo de la Guerra de Ucrania
y las acciones las sanciones políticas y
económicas que pesan sobre Moscú
qué tal Santiago muy buenas noches en
primer lugar Muchas gracias por tenerme
en cuenta para este debate para mí es un
honor estar con ustedes y también por
supuesto compartir este debate con con
clara que es una gran colega a ver la
palabra desafío implica muchas cosas Yo
creo que igualmente la posición de India
respecto de lo que es la invasión de
Ucrania por parte de Rusia no es Ni más
ni menos que una continuidad sobre su
lineamiento política exterior que tiene
desde prácticamente su independencia
India desde que se independizó ha
mantenido un digamos una posesión de no
alinearse ante ninguna de las potencias
esto surge a partir obviamente la
conferencia de bandum luego podríamos
decir que este no alineamiento avilado
hacia un multialíneamiento y
particularmente esto le ha permitido en
lo que respecta a Rusia puntualmente es
tener una muy buena relación en términos
de defensa en términos nucleares en
términos energéticos Por lo cual tomar
una posición en contra de Rusia implica
por supuesto básicamente perjudicarse y
limitarse en la posición de esos
recursos yo no sé si es que decía a
occidente en realidad está manteniendo
su propia postura y se mantiene ahí
maniobrando en un equilibrio muy claro
un equilibrio que no debe ser fácil de
mantener dada la coyuntura que estamos
viviendo en este momento Sabrina le doy
la palabra ahora Clara a nuestra
siguiente invitada también le doy la
bienvenida al programa Gracias por
acompañarnos Clara allí También desde la
ciudad de Buenos Aires Punto de partida
la misma pregunta India está desafiando
a occidente está tal vez pensando un
poco las líneas de relaciones con
algunos actores importantes de la
comunidad internacional al mantener esas
relaciones estrecha que hay nueva de
Moscú
Buenas noches Santiago también gracias
por la invitación a este debate con
Sabrina que que lo tenemos
constantemente en nuestro trabajo diario
en relación a la India en la Argentina
yo sostengo un poco lo que venía
diciendo Sabrina de que la India lo que
tiene es una política exterior Clara en
la que tiene
unos ciertos ejes que pretende cumplir
el largo plazo y uno de los cuales es
justamente el no alineamiento a ninguno
a ningún
eje O facción sino bregar por justamente
este multilateralismo que es en donde se
siente más cómoda en donde siente que
puede cumplir sus desafíos y sus
objetivos tanto
desafíos me refiero al crecimiento
económico al llevar a la India a otra a
posicionamiento como actor global y
justamente jugar ese rol no de entender
que la India es un actor global que mira
primero hacia el sur que mira primero a
los países en vías de desarrollo y que
en cierta manera vamos a usar esta
palabra que quizás es más de los 60 que
de ahora desafía cierta manera a esto a
este desarrollo a este mundo
desarrollado y Busca un posicionamiento
que está basado justamente en
romper estas brechas que existen entre
el desarrollo y el subdesarrollo y parte
de esa política exterior en la que se
monta tiene que ver con esto
En relación a
Moscú sus lazos Como dijo Sabrina son
históricos y tienen que ver también con
las intenciones que las necesidades que
tiene la India en este caso
Rusia es un actor importante porque la
India necesita de la energía que Rusia
vende Entonces tampoco
puede soltar amarras en este vínculo
porque justamente al no tener
energía la India propia como para poder
cumplir sus metas de desarrollo necesita
de Moscú claro continuó con usted para
hacer la ronda a la inversa usted habla
de una política exterior Clara y sin
alineamientos quiero que profundicemos
para entender bien esta política
exterior para luego ver cómo es la
relación con actores fundamentales como
Rusia y China que los vamos a analizar
más adelante
entendamos entonces El Punto de partida
de esta política exterior de India qué
es lo que busca entonces ser un país
fuerte a nivel regional o ser un actor a
nivel internacional o como ustedes
explicaban un actor que se relaciona con
potencias con países emergentes con
países en vías de desarrollo un país que
tiene múltiples relaciones como como es
el punto de partida de esas relaciones a
ver si nosotros vemos la política
exterior de la India y vemos los
distintos documentos que la India
desarrolla tenemos como un eje central
que su vecindario es su núcleo duro de
relacionamiento o sea el Asia del sur El
Asia Pacífico y de ahí de ampliando
distintos círculos
concéntricos todos de relacionamiento O
sea primero su vecindario después
podemos llegar a decir su continente y
después el mundo pero a su vez tiene una
estrategia que tiene que ver con lo que
decía yo antes de el mundo desarrollado
y el mundo en vías de desarrollo no que
esto tiene que ver con la conferencia de
bandum que si todo antes Sabrina que es
una cosmovisión que ellos tienen de del
mundo no que este mundo con grandes
discrepancias entre el norte y el sur no
es justo y que hay que modificar ciertas
reglas no
y Clara Cuál es su opinión sobre este
tema sobre los ejes centrales de la
política exterior de India
son consecuentes que es desde el 48 la
palabra
Sí perdón
no no no hay ningún problema
es así O sea la política exterior de
India es muy coherente con con su
historia a partir de la independencia
India Ya de por sí es el ejemón de hacia
el sur esto que Clara mencionaba como su
vecindaria no Y actualmente bajo el
gobierno de narendra modi hay una
política muy puntual que se llama
neighborhost es decir primero el
vecindario y esto implica que frente a
un conflicto frente a una situación que
amerita la ayuda por parte de alguno de
los países del vecindario India va a
estar ahí apoyando brindando su
cooperación y brindando posiblemente
apoyo económico Por supuesto que esto te
extiende a nivel globales porque India
realmente es un actor global y quiere
serlo o sea lo es y además trabaja
permanente permanentemente para llegar a
hacerlo en efecto está presente todas
las discusiones multilaterales está
presente en todos los foros
multilaterales en el g20 cuando es
invitado por el g7 también se presenta
es un país que efectivamente quiere
marcar agenda y que sabiendo que es un
país internamente multicultural multi
religioso entiende que todas estas
diferencias internas le brindan un Plus
respecto de lo que es el entendimiento
del mundo y del escenario global porque
India entiende que estamos en un mundo
multipolar y que entonces Esas
diferencias internas le va a permitir
desarrollarse mucho mejor en el ámbito
internacional en ese ánimo Sabrina por
tratar de ser un actor internacional
se ha acuñado recientemente el término
Indo Pacífico ya no es Asia Pacífico tal
vez dejando un poco de lado a China o
tratando de disminuir un poco esa
importancia de china en la influencia
que pueda haber en la Cuenca del
Pacífico y ya se habla de indopacífico
India puede extender digamos sus
tentáculos
Más allá de su zona de influencia en el
sudeste asiático y estar presente con
una excelente relación con países como
por ejemplo Australia o Nueva Zelanda o
todos estos pequeños estados insulares
allí en el Pacífico que tienen una
relación cercana con China
Sí bueno a ver digamos en el continente
asiático y particularmente la región
donde está India donde está en China el
único país que podría llegar a hacerle
un poco de frente al avance de China es
India y por eso tiene el apoyo de
Estados Unidos en diversas cuestiones lo
que pasa es que India no cuenta con el
mismo recursos materiales de china con
lo cual ahí ya se encuentra frente a un
freno de todos modos
India tiene una serie de iniciativas
sobre el lindo Pacífico en relación a su
desarrollo marítimo y demás pero lo que
pasa es que lo ha hecho recién en la
época de los 2000 digo no es India no
tuvo una conciencia cierta acerca de la
importancia de lo que era el océano
Índico y sus extensiones hasta tanto ya
India No leí ya china no lo hizo de
manera muy profunda y muy clara de todos
modos ya vamos a decir que a fines de la
década de los 90 había establecido toda
una política de mirar hacia
este con fines por supuesto al principio
económicos pero después se fueron
extendiendo a cuestiones más de defensa
comerciales hay incluso hasta también
culturales y políticas y particularmente
con este gobierno con la arena que está
en el poder desde el 2014 esta visión de
mirar se convierte o vamos a decir que
se transforma a una política en realidad
de actuar hacia esa región y por eso
mismo es que participa También de todo
lo que tiene que ver con el cual por
ejemplo
hoy la palabra aclara para hablar
específicamente quiero que entre las dos
construyan un poco el panorama de cómo
es la relación con Rusia por este
momento de tensión que hay por la
coyuntura de la guerra en Ucrania
occidente Europa específicamente de
Estados Unidos se han empeñado en
Mostrar esta propaganda digamoslo así de
que Rusia es el actor el malo de la
película
para que los demás se pongan de su lado
pero hoy en día ha evitado tomar una
posición frente al conflicto de Ucrania
no ha criticado a Rusia por la invasión
y tampoco ha impuesto las sanciones
internacionales que le han pedido
algunos países de occidente Cómo se
entiende entonces esa relación tan
cercana con Moscú
es una relación histórica entre India y
Rusia y para sumar datos en relación a
la pregunta que le hacían recién a
Sabrina y poner un claro ejemplo de
Rusia en este vínculo el primer
portaaviones que tiene la India que lo
tiene hace muy pocos años
es de origen ruso
se lo compraron a ellos y fue el primer
impulso que tomó la India para poder a
salir hacia hacia esta estrategia de
lindo Pacífico digamos no porque para
ser parte de lindo Pacífico uno tiene
que tener medios para tener presencia
entonces que mejor que tener un
portaaviones no O sea como ejemplo del
músculo militar y la presencia Clara y
firme de la India esto no lo hubiese
podido hacer sin la colaboración y el y
la compra de este de este buque a Rusia
por ejemplo otro ejemplo es la las
compras que en los últimos meses a Rusia
de justamente de gas y de petróleo para
para autoabastecerse y eventualmente si
es necesario vender parte de esta compra
que ha hecho a un precio más barato que
el mercado por justamente las sanciones
que existen contra Rusia y esto es un
beneficio que va a usar o sea India es
muy pragmática no va no va a torcer su
su política exterior pese a las
presiones que pueden venir de parte de
Estados Unidos de la Unión Europea y de
distintos otros países que quieren una
declaración más fuerte del gobierno de
modic en relación a Rusia yo creo que
esto no va a pasar va a ir en lo intentó
varias veces y no hasta ahora no ha
podido no sí a ver Clara es importante
creo que aclarar ahí esa presión que
puede ejercer occidente sobre el
gobierno de naranja y por la relación
qué tan importante Entonces es aquí
necesario hacer balance por ejemplo de
parte de Estados Unidos o presionar a
India por esta relación que tiene con
Moscú por temor a que se vuelva un punto
de tránsito para suministrar alimentos a
Rusia para poder acceder a todos esos
productos que están vetados por las
sanciones internacionales y también para
el flujo de capitales y dinero a través
de bancos de la India que ya de hecho lo
está haciendo al comprar
petróleo Ruso y pagarlo en bancos en los
emiratos árabes ya ahí está haciendo un
bypass a las sanciones internacionales
Estados Unidos qué tanto puede presionar
allí o qué tan importante es India para
Estados Unidos para decir prefiero no
tocarlo O no me importa yo aprieto Nueva
Delhi hasta que reviente y se aleje de
Moscú
yo creo que en los últimos años el
vínculo en Nueva Delhi Washington ha
crecido de una manera
sustancial pero todavía falta robustez
falta enraizar estos vínculos existen
pero también existe la desconfianza la
India es un actor muy importante para
Estados Unidos en este momento porque
recordemos que
hay un conflicto abierto entre dos
estados nuclearizados que son la India
de Pakistán después está el conflicto
aún no cerrado de Afganistán con los con
el gobierno talibán y después tenemos el
otro gran conflicto que en cierta manera
Sabrina ya algo dijo que es China la
contención de China tanto en el Índico
como en el Pacífico bueno la India es un
actor necesario para Estados Unidos para
ejercer esta contención porque
recordemos que tienen todavía un
conflicto abierto limítrofe India y
China Pese a que son importantes socios
comerciales los unos con los otros
India es un actor que hoy Estados Unidos
necesita para ejercer esta política de
contención hacia china pero tampoco es
un actor 100%
confiable para Estados Unidos
O sea está confiabilidad va creciendo
pero todavía están desarrollo
en desarrollo yo creo Sabrina que esa
confianza por parte de Washington puede
quedar en entredicho a la luz y a los
ojos de la Casa Blanca no digo el resto
del mundo occidental por ese corredor
comercial que se está Armando con otro
importante antagonista de todo el
escenario internacional que es Irán ya
está establecida esta ruta marítima que
sale de puertos del occidente de India a
través del estrecho ormus a los puertos
iraníes y de ahí hasta el caspio y de
ahí llegan a territorio Ruso y se está
Armando este corredor comercial entre
estos tres países aquí occidente que
puede decir de este corredor comercial y
esta relación nueva de literal Moscú
Bueno en realidad puede decir mucho pero
hay que ver realmente Cuáles son las
consecuencias directas y concretas
acerca de lo que puede llegar a decir y
con esto me refiero puntualmente a por
ejemplo dos situaciones que se dieron
cuando el cancillers el canciller indio
visitó Washington hace cuestión de mes y
medio dos meses
efectivamente le dieron una conferencia
de prensa le le dan a entender porque o
sea el link que le da a entender que
estaba muy preocupado por el respeto de
los Derechos Humanos en India etcétera
etcétera o sea obviamente ejerciendo una
cierta presión para que India finalmente
tome posición
igualmente Yo creo que India tiene una
posesión El problema es que no es la
posesión que quiere Estados Unidos
pero bueno frente digo a esta situación
en la que el secretario de estado
particularmente lendilga India que no se
respetan los Derechos Humanos el
canciller muy tranquilamente le dijo
Bueno Nosotros también estamos muy
supuesto que los Derechos Humanos que se
violan en Estados Unidos de los Derechos
Humanos entonces lo que a mí me parece
que está pasando particularmente con
India es que van a poder
achacarle diversas situaciones van a
poder decirle India no toma una posición
concreta India no toma la posición
necesaria India es una democracia Por
qué no está respetando ciertas
cuestiones El problema es que hasta
tanto India no se alinea con los
intereses de Estados Unidos va a seguir
recibiendo algún tipo de cuestionamiento
yo lo que creo y un poco comparto lo que
decía este Clara anteriormente India
tiene su política exterior
y claramente sus objetivos necesita su
desarrollo económico está en un
vecindario complejo porque tiene dos
vecinos limítrofes aquí están y china
con los cuales tiene conceptos latentes
son hipótesis permanentes Entonces
siempre Tampoco puede y si se me permite
la expresión pegarse un tiro en el pie
vínculos con otros países
pese a la oposición de Estados Unidos la
va a tener a tener
haciendo y leyendo varios de los
análisis que hay de la reciente tensión
que se ha incrementado entre Beijing y
taipei a raíz de la visita de de esta
representante de bueno la presidenta la
cámara de representantes a la isla de
Taiwán desde la India se toma esto con
muy mucha delicadeza y con pinzas porque
les parece que de pronto India Perdón
china no tocaría a Taiwán pero en ese
orden de ideas de tratar de Mostrar un
poco su posición tratar de mostrar su
fortalecimiento militar de los últimos
años puede atacar un objetivo blando en
la región no algo fuerte como sería
Taiwán y podría ser general otra vez
tensión en la frontera con India ataques
como ya sucedió en meses pasados o
incluso hace un par de años algunos
soldados indios murieron allí en la
frontera y hubo algunos enfrentamientos
entre los dos lados esto podría llevar a
que India se diera la presión de Estados
Unidos un escenario así como lo ve usted
Clara para esta necesidad que tiene
India de defenderse de China dado el
caso que haya un tipo de agresión
de hecho
la disputa
en la que fue en su momento muy hace dos
años cuando fue la campaña política la
última campaña política para reelegir a
la actual Primer Ministro modi pasó Esto
justamente De que murieron varios
soldados indios en enfrentamientos con
china a ver yo creo que
la diplomacia en general en Asia es muy
pragmática y no no obedece mucho a las
presiones extranjeras sino que tiene que
ver con los lineamientos internos de
cada uno de los estados y esto aplica
tanto para la India como para china
también entonces las presiones de
Estados Unidos son relativas hoy y ellos
se las toman de manera relativa porque
para para Asia al negociar y el retomar
todo el tiempo
Los lazos de conexión y charlar y hablar
y reacordar algo que un día dijimos
blanco y mañana dijimos negro y vamos a
llegar un gris y vamos a tardar seis mil
años en hacerlo bueno Esto es parte
natural del ejercicio de la diplomacia
en todo el continente asiático Entonces
no existe un no totalmente absoluto ni
tampoco un sí absoluto sino que existe
una gama Denis o de niñez en el medio
que
nos permiten hacer muchas cosas al mismo
tiempo con un montón de actores y
Sabrina sobre este tema sobre esa
posibilidad que un enfrentamiento con
china lleve a que India tenga que ceder
antepresiones de Estados Unidos solo
para poderse defender y le prolonga un
poco más la la pregunta y es si esta
atención con Beijing obedece a que India
se siente vulnerable por lo menos en
términos militares frente a China
bueno empiezo por esto último que vos
decís India y China mantuvieron un
conflicto armado en 1962 en ese momento
India mantenía firmemente su política de
no alineamiento y precisamente es ahí
cuando china le gana esa ese conflicto a
India India se siente absolutamente
humillada y decide en algún punto dejar
de lado un poco este este no
alineamiento porque En definitiva cuando
lo necesitó nadie lo vine a rescatar
entonces
creo Igualmente que India se sabe que no
están en la misma posición de la India
de 1962 y de esto de hecho esto es algo
que que lo ha dicho algún funcionario
indio cuando ha habido escaramuzas entre
India y China Pero de todos modos
sabemos que no cuenta con los mismos
recursos materiales y esto es un hecho
de todos modos esto no significa
que vaya a ceder completamente a
cualquier presión de cualquier potencia
extranjera y esto lo digo porque in de
China mantienen una una frontera de
3.500 kilómetros mantiene conflictos en
dos puntos fronterizos cada vez que las
escaramuzas adquieren como un nivel de
mayor preocupación finalmente por ahí se
encuentran
y de manera informal y Resuelve los
conflictos y luego vuelve todo a bajar o
sea esas tensiones vuelven a bajar o lo
cual yo no sé si India necesita tener a
esas presiones de Estados Unidos Porque
además con China si bien tiene estos
problemas limítrofes tiene un excelente
relación comercial entonces en algún
punto la relación es tan agridulce y se
necesitan Claro que por qué habría de
cumplir los designios de Estados Unidos
claro además tienen un punto en común a
nivel comercial a nivel estratégico y es
el escenario de los bricks un grupo que
ha perdido fuerza a nivel internacional
y político en los últimos años pero allí
una relación por lo menos en el punto de
máxima expresión de este grupo a nivel
internacional era bastante fluida esa
relación que vuelve y entra moscúa allí
También entra Brasil y entra Sudáfrica
pero a nivel comercial son países que se
entienden muy bien es extraño entender
esa relación de nos mostramos los
dientes en la frontera pero a nivel
comercial casi que nos complementamos en
algunos mercados
Sabrina
Sí bueno exactamente Igualmente Más allá
de que de que bricks sea un foro que no
está institucionalizado y demás sigue
siendo un punto de encuentro y y de
hecho hay como cierto relanzamiento en
los últimos tiempos Fíjate que que
abrieron el juego hacia otros países y e
incluso la propia Argentina está
invitada a formar parte de los brits no
yo creo Igualmente que más allá de todos
estos conflictos
hay una cuestión que tiene que ver con
digamos el aspecto nuclear y que
impide obliga Mejor dicho A cada una de
las naciones que están involucradas
realmente pensar muy bien cuando van a
desatar un conflicto y se lo van a
desatar Hasta qué punto se puede jugar Y
hasta qué punto No
importante ese punto clara le pregunto
en este escenario internacional el que
estamos detenciones conflicto en Ucrania
tensiones con Rusia Washington Bruselas
Beijing un mundo también saliendo de una
crisis económica generalizada y tratando
de levantarse después de los
confinamientos que dejó la pandemia de
Kobe 19 en ese escenario china Qué papel
puede jugar como un actor internacional
Aprovechando que bueno más que bien
tiene buenas relaciones con Moscú se
lleva bien con Europa
le interesaría tener ese papel de
intermediario en en algunas resolución
de conflictos
en la resolución de conflictos como
intermediario para el diálogo sí como
para intervenir dentro de las políticas
internas de cada uno de los países no y
claramente no porque justamente uno de
los principios núcleo de China es la no
intervención o la y no injerencia en
asuntos internos de los estados por lo
tanto es muy difícil que china
habilite una invasión habilite una una
intervención de fuerzas de paz a un
tercer estado porque justamente brega
porque eso no no no ocurra digamos pero
sí es un actor importante a la hora de
sentarnos en el diálogo internacional y
juega un rol porque es la segunda
Economía del mundo es es el hegemon
junto con India en Asia en el lindo
Pacífico tiene un rol súper importante
porque tiene influencia muy grande con
los países del sudeste asiático con los
países de las pequeñas islas del Asia
del Pacífico
es un es un actor muy importante pero
[Música]
respeta siempre el principio de no
injerencia no O sea para él es es
fundamental y es la base de su de sus
lineamientos En política internacional
junto con la India comparten esta esta
idea de que en cierta manera el orden
internacional actual no representa ni
los intereses de China por un lado ni
los de Asia por el otro entonces
propone en cierta manera una reforma en
la Que obviamente china tenga un rol
patagónico que el que tiene hoy no más
protagónico claro que si paso ya a la
parte final del programa Sabrina Quiero
preguntarle por el área de influencia en
la que está ubicada India que es un país
enorme sumamente extenso solamente para
darles algunos datos a los televidentes
el océano Índico que es a donde tiene
acceso India al mar y es donde están
ubicados sus diferentes puertos conecta
con 34 estados litorales entre los que
está por supuesto Pakistán Irán que es
un actor importante que está en el Golfo
Pérsico Arabia Saudita dos tercios del
comercio marítimo global transitan por
estas aguas y también dos tercios del
total del petróleo y de Gas del mundo
atraviesan por este océano es un punto
muy importante los puertos de la India
son sumamente importantes como está la
presencia de India en esos países de su
zona de influencia la relación se
mantiene fuerte o ha perdido terreno
ante la presencia de China que llega
ofreciendo la elaboración y construcción
infraestructura precios muy bajos
veíamos el caso de sri lanka que le tuvo
que entregar su Puerto más grande a una
concesión china porque no tiene como
pagarlo y muchos se preguntaron India
Qué papel podía jugar en esa
estabilización política de de esa de esa
isla y prácticamente brilló por su
ausencia
bueno la idea que venimos diciendo India
no tiene los mismos recursos materiales
de China fin de lo que puede hacer es
prestar su cooperación
sobre todo en términos por ejemplo de
salud en términos de infraestructura
en bienes en algunos alimentos tal vez
medicamentos eso desde ya en algunos
servicios pero realmente no tiene los
mismos recursos materiales que tiene
China estos recursos de grandes
proyectos de infraestructura Y eso lo
que hace también es que India también se
replantea algunas cuestiones a nivel
interno porque porque India si bien es
cierto que tiene muy buenas tasas de
crecimiento por lo menos lo tenía antes
de la pandemia y se está recuperando y
se estima que a fines de este año el año
que viene pueda recuperar esos niveles
Lo cierto es que también tiene muchas
dificultades a nivel interno y y estas
vamos a decir desigualdades sociales
económicas etcétera le imponen también
pensar estratégicamente de dónde
destinar sus recursos y
eso esto opera como un freno también
para ciertas cuestiones que tiene que
ver con India respecto de su política
claro esa dificultades internas la vemos
por ejemplo ahora de la crisis de
suministro de cereales y granos de
Ucrania Rusia India era la gran
Esperanza a nivel internacional y el
gobierno dijo no vamos a exportar ni un
solo gramo lo vamos a dejar para el
consumo interno y ahí fue cuando los
precios se dispararon y empezó el
desabastecimiento a nivel internacional
obviamente pues por toda esta situación
que se estaba viviendo en Ucrania pero
predominó allí el interés nacional el
interés de la necesidad de tener que
alimentar a sus a sus habitantes antes
que exportar y llevar ganancias a las
arcas del Estado su impresión Clara De
esta zona de influencia en el en la zona
del Índico
a ver Me parece que con Siri lanka India
intentó en los últimos meses tratar de
justamente con los pocos recursos que
tiene o los o los exiguos en relación a
China recursos que tiene para colaborar
en Siri lanka lo hizo
entregó medicamentos entregó arroz
intentó saldar un poco esta hambruna que
estaba incipiente
en sri lanka digamos
creo que
cada vez entiende con más velocidad y
con más necesidad de de poder ahondar y
estrechar los vínculos que tiene en el
en el Índico con los recursos
disponibles como dice Sabrina creo que
el desarrollo de la diplomacia es muy
importante en esto para ellos o sea el
contacto con los distintos gobiernos
de la Cuenca del Índico para ellos es
importante Por eso invita a Nueva Delhi
da cursos por ejemplo el programa itec
de la cual tanta Sabrina como yo somos
beneficiarias y hemos estudiado en la
India las dos bajo Este programa es un
programa que le sirve muy claramente
para estrechar los vínculos con la
Cuenca del Índico y con el África por
ejemplo a la India Bueno pues me queda
creo que un minuto para finalizar el
programa conclusiones rápidamente
Sabrina que puede esperarse de este país
en este escenario internacional tan
convulsó en este momento que podemos ver
de India en los próximos meses
India tiene un excelente canciller
y evidentemente sabe maniobrar muy bien
y mantener tratar de mantener el
equilibrio frente a todas las potencias
yo creo que India es un país que nos va
a dar que hablar en los próximos 30 40
años no hay que perderla del radar Sí
muy a pesar de las dificultades internas
que tiene Pero de todos modos es un
actor global y va a seguir estando
presente en el escenario internacional y
claro su conclusión para el cierre del
programa
repetir la de Sabrina con lo cual
yo adscribo totalmente voy a decir que
India últimamente está mirando hacia su
oeste y América Latina es una
oportunidad para establecer justamente y
profundizar los vínculos que existen
entre Nueva Delhi y toda latinoamérica
creo que se viene eso ahora una relación
más cercana con América Latina una
relación que prácticamente ha estado
enfocada en Brasil a través de los
bricks una relación muy muy buena entre
Brasil en Nueva Delhi en los últimos
años eso lo hemos visto pues a Sabrina y
aclara les agradezco mucho muy
interesante este tema muy interesante
comprender el papel de este país para
las relaciones internacionales y lo que
está sucediendo en el mundo en este
momento veremos que vamos a ver por
parte de India en los próximos meses en
este escenario global les agradezco
mucho por haber hecho este análisis y
ustedes sigan en sintonía de France 24
[Música]